JELENA PJESIVAC-GRBOVIC: Hello.
Hello, everyone, and welcome.
Hadoop and its ecosystem has
become increasingly important
to businesses of every type.
Hadoop holds the
promise that it will
unlock the value of
your data and give you
the insights that will help
you flourish your business.
Now, you're here, so
maybe you're aware of,
or you personally experienced,
that the overheads of managing
Hadoop infrastructures
are not so small.
As the number and
sophistication of the workloads
we run increases, so does
the operational overhead
of our clusters too.
This increase in the overhead
undermines the core value
proposition that Hadoop
brings to the table.
Essentially, it takes
away focus from the data
onto how to run the cluster.
This is where Google
Cloud Platform and Cloud
Dataproc come in.
My name is Jelena
Pjesivac-Grbovic.
I'm tech leader
manager at Google.
And today, we will see how
your migration to cloud
and the incremental
changes to the way
you run your Hadoop
and Spark workloads
can let you preserve the power
of the open source system
that you've built and reduce
the operational complexity,
allowing you to
refocus on the data.
This is a journey.
Migration to the cloud
doesn't have a one way
that works for everyone.
There are many
valid paths to take.
We will highlight some
overarching guidelines
and the principles, and identify
useful building blocks that
will make the migration to
cloud easier and smoother
and allow you to benefit
earlier from the new stack.
So let's begin with what
is Google Cloud Dataproc.
Google Cloud Dataproc is managed
Hadoop and Spark service.
Its goal is to help you
refocus your efforts
to your data instead of
managing the cluster.
Dataproc achieves this by being
fast, easy, and cost effective.
What do I mean by that?
Imagine a new version
of Hadoop is coming out.
It promises to make
your critical workload
10 times faster.
Sounds great, right?
What would it take for you
to deploy this new version
of Hadoop in your data center?
Think of the testing,
validation, qualification,
and everything else.
But Dataproc-- this would
be a one line command,
or alternatively a few clicks.
About 90 seconds after
that command line,
you would have a brand new
data or cluster with a version
that you want, and you would be
ready to canary your workloads
even at the production scale.
The speed and simplicity
at which you can run--
I don't what's this--
at which you can run
and start the clusters
lends itself to
cost effectiveness,
because you can run the
cluster and the resources
only when you need them.
There is a whole
spectrum of approaches
on running Hadoop on GCP.
Starting with an
on-premise, right, we
can have any of
these options there.
And where you're on
the spectrum depends on
whether you treat GCP as
infrastructure as a service
or as a platform as a service.
Along the spectrum, GCP
works with many partners that
will help your
migration, and you don't
have to be alone on this path.
So lets look at how the Dataproc
works and how's it is built.
Dataproc layers the features
on top of the standard Hadoop
stack.
Between the Hadoop layers,
we insert the monitoring,
statuses, configuration
options, things like that,
that augment the Hadoop stack
and make it more manageable.
We built our functionality using
native, open source APIs, which
means that whatever you did
for your own customization
in your own cluster
will work in Dataproc.
You will have a full power--
how you access these clusters.
You can use your
standard APIs that you're
used to, like Hadoop
command line-- you know,
ssh to the master.
Or you can use our Rust APIs
and our UI third party tools
that we are integrated with.
It's your choice.
Our distro is based
on the Bigtop,
and it comes with Hadoop,
Spark, Hive, and Pig by default.
They are enabled immediately.
We provide you with ability to
enable Tez, Zeppelin, and Kafka
via something we called
initialization actions.
So imagine you are
in a place where
you are enticed with a cloud,
and you want to try it out.
So what should be
your next step?
You should be planning
your Proof of Concept, POC.
During the POC, you
will have to think about
what will it take to move
your on premise solution
to the cloud.
You will think about mechanics.
You know, how can I do this?
But we encourage
you to think bigger.
You should think about
the opportunities
to simplify your stack, as well.
And as you proceed
with POC, this design
is going to be really important.
Concretely, on
thinking the bigger--
in your on-premise
setup, Hadoop clusters
are likely the core
of your data platform.
In Cloud, they're just one
of the building blocks,
and you can have
many building blocks
and many different
building blocks.
Example of the building
blocks we'll mention today--
and you probably
heard today, also,
things like GCS, BigQuery,
Bigtable, Pub/Sub, Dataflow,
Stackdriver, machine
learning, right?
All of these can eventually
become parts of your platform
that's maybe just starting with
Dataproc and Hadoop, right?
So when you think of migration,
you should lift your platform,
and you should leverage
these things, as well.
When starting the POC, you need
to identify your high level
goals for the
migration, and you want
them to be clear
and well understood.
Some of the goals are on
here, like cost savings.
What does the cost
saving mean to you?
Is it the total
cost of ownership,
or it is the cost
performance balance?
Like you want more performance
for the same amount of money.
What you do, depending
on which of these two
goals you care about more--
it will depend on which of these
two goals you actually have.
You have concerns about
the scaling elasticity.
Do you want to
solve that problem
by having multiple clusters?
Or you'll go a step
further, and you
will disaggregate your
storage and compute.
And then you can have as
many clusters as you want,
and you can even throw
different tools on your data.
Development agility, like,
how do you handle versioning?
Do you care about heterogeneous
dependencies and et cetera?
You don't have to--
when you think of
these goals, you
don't have to make significant
changes to your stack.
But you want to consciously
think of the goals you have
and do the analysis of--
concretely do the analysis
of the cost and benefits
of keeping something
the same or trying
to change it in a process.
So we now have goals,
which is great,
but we have to understand
our requirements,
the characteristics of
your current solution,
existing system, and also
the timeline that you have
in mind for this migration.
To get to the requirements,
you should look at the tools
that you're currently using.
What are the components?
What are the components
you actually want to keep?
Because some of the
components are really
the requirement, and
some of the components
you added because you had to.
It was a hack around the
problem you had, right?
So perhaps that
hack doesn't have
to go with you to the cloud.
Maybe there is a better
solution there, right?
Think about capacity planning.
You're going to
use the Dataproc,
so you're still responsible
for sizing your clusters.
So think about how
much compute you need.
What are the average peak?
And what is the peak, and
what's average data throughput
that you want to support?
Think of the security models.
And finally, thinking
of the timeline
is important, because depending
the duration of migration
that you have in
mind, you may have
to build a hybrid
infrastructure that
will host both your current
on-prem thing and the cloud
cluster.
OK, so we talked
about the planning.
You've done your planning.
You have your goals.
What is the first step?
The first step will
be the data migration.
So usually when you're
thinking of data migration,
you look at your storage options
and the types of data you have.
At the cloud-- at GCP, we have
quite a few storage solutions.
The standard one is
Google Cloud Storage,
which is our large
scale object store that
is accessible through
File-Based API.
We also gave you two
flavors of the HDFS--
one based on the
persistent disks and one
on the local SSDs.
Then, if you use Hive,
we have a cloud Bigtable,
and we have BigQuery.
We also have Spanner
and many other products
that could meet your needs.
So you should evaluate
them, understand
whatever benefits and
drawbacks are, and then you
should look at your data.
And usually, one
of the first data
sets that moves to the cloud
is archival and call data--
the stuff you have to take care
of, but you don't really use.
So that's usually the first
thing that moves to the cloud.
And then you start moving
parts of the live, hot data,
and you start computing with it.
You do want to--
one thing that's important
is how you access the data.
So to choose which
storage option you want,
you really want to think
whether the data set requires
random access or not.
So again, the first movers--
yeah.
And one thing to
think about is, like,
if you have to have a
hybrid architecture,
you need to figure
out the solution that
will allow you to keep the
same data set in two places.
And the partners are
really helpful with that.
OK, so GCS is usually the first
GCP solution you will use.
So I would like to call out
some differences between GCP
and HDFS.
I'm assuming you're
familiar with the HDFS.
So GCP is our object store.
And for the most
part, you can use it
as a drop-in
replacement for HDFS.
It has a Hadoop file
system interface.
All your I/O connectors based
file, input/output formats,
contexts of text file,
et cetera, just work.
A nice thing with
GCS connector is also
that you can install it on
your own on-premise cluster.
But GCS, you will get the
cleaner architecture, why?
Because the data will live
outside of your cluster.
It will live in our
distributed storage that is
replicated across the zones--
perhaps multi-regionally
if that's how you want it.
And you can throw
any compute on it.
You you're not limited
to just the compute
that you have in your cluster.
Another nice thing of
the GCS is that there
is no concept of a NameNode.
So if you ever experienced
killability issues
in your clusters due to
NameNode performance,
this does not exist.
There's no such thing here.
And you also no longer have
a single point of failure.
To optimize GCS performance,
conveniently, you
use the same approaches
like you optimize HDFS.
So you want to optimize for
bulk and parallel operations.
So the pros of GCS
are high throughput,
no scaling bottlenecks, no
single point of failure,
and the data can be durable
across the zones and regions.
There are some drawbacks.
With the fact that
there is no NameNode
and that you're across
the zones and regions,
your latency can go up.
Directories in
GCS are simulated.
So if your application
relies on checking
a timestamp of a directory,
there is no such thing.
So you either have to
modify the application,
or you have to use HDFS, right?
And objects in GCS cannot be
appended once they're closed.
So these are sort of things
to think about when you want
to move the data sets to GCS.
So, OK, we want to
move the data sets.
What approaches can we take?
Well, we can push it,
or we can pull it.
Those are two, generally,
approaches you can do.
Push approach is--
I'm in my on-prem cluster.
I connect to the
GCS via GCS APIs,
and I copy the data
from my cluster to GCS.
It's simple.
It has a straightforward
security model.
Your data is encrypted
with SSL, and it
goes through internet
gateways like this.
So you are in your
on-prem cluster,
and you send your data to GCS.
OK, so that's the
simplest model.
The downside of this
model is that you're
using your compute and on-prem
cluster to move the data.
So if you were resource
constraint on your cluster,
this is sort of--
you're using more resources.
Alternative model
is a pull model.
So in a pull model,
I set up the VPN
such that my cloud cluster
can access the data on my
on premise cluster.
You really want to
do this carefully.
And from there you
use the compute
in your cloud to just pull the
data from your on-prem cluster.
From there, the
data can go either
on your HDFS in the cloud, or
to storage, or to BigQuery.
It doesn't matter.
All of these are options.
The main difference
in a security model
in the pull approach,
your security
relies on you setting up the
VPN properly and ensuring
that you can set up
the permissions such
that only you can
access the data.
So let's take a look at
some of the cloud native
architectural concepts.
On your on-prem cluster, the
data locality was premium.
And essentially, you were
computing over the data
that existed in your cluster.
That was done for performance
reasons and convenience
reasons, because
usually when you decided
you needed a
petabyte of storage,
you bought a cluster that
had a petabyte of storage,
and it came with some CPUs.
Your computations come
and go in a cluster,
but your data sits there.
So the computation and the data
have very different lifespans
for the most part.
So why not just separate them?
Why do we have to
tie the computation
to the lifespan of the data?
And the process
of disaggregation
of storage and compute
is essentially separating
data plane from the computing.
We essentially pull out
the data from the machines.
So if this is our
cluster, we no longer
keep data inside a cluster, but
we use GCS, BigQuery, Bigtable,
Spanner, whichever
data storage you chose.
And our clusters are
there for computing.
And when we're done computing,
maybe we can get rid of them.
At the same time, we also--
our clusters will produce some
data, such as monitoring data,
and log in data,
and stuff like that.
And then it will also live
outside of the cluster.
It will come out of it.
Because we don't want to keep--
this information
is useful even when
the computation is done so we
separated from the computation.
So this gives you quite
a bit of flexibility
on how you manage
cluster lifespan.
But another thing
that it gives you also
is ability to burst in Cloud.
What do I mean by that?
In Cloud, a job, a task, that
will take 1,000 CPU hours
will cost the same if it runs
on 1,000 machines for one hour
or on 10 machines for 100 hours.
The math adds up.
The CPU usage, disk usage,
RAM usage adds up, right?
But it's very likely
that that value
is way more valuable to you
if you waited one hour for it
as opposed to 100 hours.
Now, if your data was
confined on the machines that
are computing,
the chances of you
being able to throw
1,000 machines on it
trivially is low.
But if you store it on something
that's highly scalable,
like GCS, you can actually
throw this many resources on it
and compute is much
faster for the same price.
Another feature of
Dataproc and is used in GCP
are preemptible VMs.
Preemptible VMs are regular VMs,
but Google reclaims the right--
Google keeps the rights
to reclaim them as needed
so they can come and go.
Usually they're there.
Because of this, they cost
only 20% of the cost of the VM.
So they are significantly
cheaper than the regular VM.
And they're sort of guaranteed
to be preempted at least once
a day.
So with Dataproc-- if you
didn't have a Dataproc,
you would have to deal
with these machines coming
and going.
You want your cluster
with 100 machines.
You have 95 now, because
five of them were preempted.
You have to find
another five, right?
With Dataproc, this is
managed for you automatically.
So you can have your
Dataproc cluster
with the preemptible VMs
costing 1/5 of the compute
that you would have with
the Dataproc cluster
with the regular VMs.
And another thing where
this is really useful
is if you separated your
storage from the compute,
the preemptible VMs don't
really cost you any loss.
They just come and go, right?
Different computations
have different resource
requirements.
So let's imagine that
our workload requires
six CPUs and eight gigs of RAM.
In Google, we have
standard instances,
and one is n1-standard-4, which
comes with four CPUs and four
gigs of RAM.
There is n1-highmem, which
comes with four CPUs and eight
gigs of RAM.
And we have n1-standard-8,
which has eight CPUs
and 1-2-3-4-5-6-7--
8 gigs of RAM.
But we need six CPUs
and eight gigs of RAM.
So you can create
your Dataproc cluster
using custom VMs, which will
have six CPUs and whatever
RAM you need there.
I guess these are four gig
chips, so let's assume eight.
So depending on
computation you want to do,
you can actually make VMs fit
the size of your computation
and just run the
Dataproc cluster with it.
These custom VMs
came out in March
and are a pretty neat
technological improvement.
You don't have to do any bin
packing of your workloads.
So now we've seen--
we separated our data
from computation.
We understand that we can
have different size machines.
So let's take this idea further.
We can right-size our clusters
based on the use case we have.
Think of the different
workloads you do.
You have a map reduce CTL.
You have some machine learning.
You do some high analytics,
and you do business reporting.
Do all these workloads need
the same computational power?
Are some of them more
valuable than others,
and you're willing to
pay more for those VMs
so the things would
finish faster?
So if you were willing to
pay for business reporting
to use these high
performance VMs,
are you willing to spend
them on MapReduce CTL?
Perhaps, perhaps not.
So if you think of the
cluster as a building block,
you can understand
that here you have,
actually, potential for
different-shaped building
blocks.
So we can have four
clusters with the VMs that
look significantly different,
have a different price
performance label
attached to them,
and we can optimize for cost.
We can optimize for speed.
And for different use case, we
can choose the right occasion.
So this is right-sizing
clusters for use case.
But we can take it
one step further.
So we can have a thermal and
semi long-lived clusters.
So at the beginning, I said
it takes us around 90 seconds
to start the Dataproc cluster.
And we'll demo that soon.
So this is pretty
immediate, right?
So we can choose the
lifetime of a cluster
according to the
workload it runs.
On one end of the spectrum
are thermal clusters.
Those are clusters that you
start to do this computation.
And then when the
computation is done,
you just leave them,
as simple as that.
I know one of our partners
does exactly that.
They have some custom
made Spark thing
that they run every night,
and it's pretty significant.
It uses around 1,000
cores or something.
So every night at
midnight they spin up
1,000 core Dataproc cluster,
run the computation,
and tear it down.
And then following
night, they do the same.
It's all automated.
The other thing
that's nice if you
treat the cluster
per computation,
like in the thermal
mode, is imagine you
have to change a region
for whatever reason.
It's essentially--
that all you have
to do in that case
is, like, we'll
start a cluster in this
region and run jobs there.
It's as simple as that.
On the other end
of the spectrum,
you'll have the semi
long-lived clusters.
And even for them, they may
end up having some data there.
Maybe you're running your own
Hive instance or something.
So you really need them
there all the time.
They cannot really
go away easily.
Coming back to one of the
use cases at the beginning--
what does it take to
install the new version?
Well, again, a few
clicks of a button
and selecting the preview
image for the latest
and the greatest, and
you start a new cluster.
You can start debugging on it.
You can start load testing
and everything else.
And once you are happy, just
migrate all your workflows
to this new cluster and
shut down the other one.
So thermal clusters allow you
to really treat computation
very differently
than you did on-prem,
but they're not required.
It is something that can be done
if it makes your life simpler.
If it doesn't, just go ahead
use the semi long-lived clusters
and benefit from
our ability to start
the clusters quickly when you
want to test the new versions.
OK, so we settle on a couple
of architectural choices.
How do we actually manage
our cluster and our jobs?
So Dataproc exposes Rust API.
And this standard
Rust API allows
you to manage cluster, jobs,
and operations on the clusters.
And we integrate with
many third party tools,
like mrjob, Luigi--
I don't know which owns--
that allow you to sort of handle
your clusters using this API.
You can also ssh
on your master node
and use your standard
Hadoop and Spark commands
that you're used
to, but we're going
to see how managing Dataproc
through these APIs look like.
So can I have my computer?
OK, so here is the
cloud platform start
page, our console, and we'll
go find the Dataproc from here.
Dataproc is here.
And this is in our demo project.
So there are four
projects right now.
Two of them are in US,
and two are in Europe,
in different zones.
And I start with
the Jelena Demo Zero
just so I make sure I
have one cluster running.
And my colleagues
run the other ones.
And we live in separate worlds.
I can't affect their
production or their demos,
and they can't
affect mine, which
is a really nice separation
sometimes to have.
So I want to create a cluster.
And here we'll click
on Create a Cluster.
And I'm going to call it--
I'm going to call it Two.
I'm going to run it
in Europe, because we
are in Europe right now.
And I'm just going to
minimally configure it.
I'm going to reduce
the size of the disks.
And I mentioned you could
try running a new version,
and that option exists here.
So you can choose
the image version.
And the preview on
is a nightly-built.
We're not going to do that.
We're just going to
keep the default.
And I'm going to click Create.
So here we see my cluster
is starting to be made.
And at the same time,
we'll do an experiment
with the command
line, which is here.
And this is essentially
the command line.
We do gcloud Dataproc clusters.
Create Jelena Demo One
with the two workers.
And this starts the operation.
So here you can see two
clusters being spun up--
like, these two.
It's readable, right?
OK, and let's see how
long does it take.
While they're spinning
up, we can look at them.
So here I already
have two workers.
So this one probably
spun up fully.
I can easily get some overview
on the CPU utilization
on what the workers--
the jobs are doing.
And I can see my configuration
at any given time.
I can check on the jobs,
but I didn't run any jobs.
So there's nothing
there right now.
Let's go back to all of them.
OK, so Demo Two started.
Demo One is still spinning up.
Let's check it out.
Again, this one also
had only two instances,
and I'm guessing it's
essentially done.
OK, so let's open another tab,
and we'll go back to that one.
So now imagine we want to
run a job, and we'll run--
I have here some Spark,
PySpark, hello world in PySpark.
It just starts a PySpark
and prints hello and world--
nothing too exciting--
perfect for demo.
OK, so our cluster started
in, like, 94 seconds.
[STOP WATCH BEEPS]
So let's go back here.
Let's run this job
using our APIs.
OK, so it copied the files.
It started operation.
And this is running on Demo One.
So I can check the jobs there.
It's running right now.
And the really cool thing
is that, essentially, you
can get the live stream of
the output in a few seconds.
You can see it finished its job,
and it printed out hello world.
Now, let's say we
wanted to run something
a slightly bit more complicated
but still demo-worthy.
Let's compute the value of pi.
OK, and this one will
run another Spark job
with 1,000 tasks
to complete this.
And this guy will run
on our Demo Two cluster.
OK, so you can see
small spikes in CPU,
the jobs that are running--
this one is running.
We have our VM instances.
Again, if I click here,
I can see it executing,
and you can see this
is the number of tasks
it just started.
So it has zero tasks,
and it completed zero.
And, I guess, the new
line is hard to add.
So we'll have a little
bit of noisy output.
But we just computed pi.
It's 3.14162.
And for everyone who knows that
it's, like, 1-4-1-5-9 whatever,
we need to recompute it better.
This is not good enough.
So let's try running a
50 times bigger problem.
So instead of 1,000 tasks,
let's do 50,000 tasks.
So this job with 1,000
tasks took 33 seconds.
We're now running
with 50,000 tasks.
And maybe we figure
out, whoops, this
is going to take 50
times 30 seconds--
I have, like, seven
more minutes-- maybe
not a good idea.
I need more resources.
So I'll edit the cluster.
And instead of two,
I'll do 100 VMs.
OK, and I got quota--
disk quota.
OK, 200 is not going to
work, but let's do 14.
Maybe I selected the
wrong zone, sorry.
Come on.
OK, let's run it on
the other cluster.
Actually, I'm really
upset with this cluster.
So I'm going to delete it.
And that one is
going to go away,
and I'm just going
to kill this guy,
and go to the
beginning of the line,
and change it to
run on Demo One.
And while we are doing
this, this cluster
is being deleted with all the
artifacts that it created.
And this one, I'm going to
increase to more machines,
because in this zone,
I know I have quota.
Come on.
OK, so the quotas are not
cooperating with me today.
So let's do 30 nodes.
Thank you.
So what does it mean?
Let's look at our VMs.
Voila.
My extra 30 VMs are
showing up, and it
will take them a few seconds.
And this is on my
Demo One cluster.
And as they start
appearing, you'll
see they're faster than
they were originally.
So in a few seconds
they're all here.
And now all that
has to happen is
that my Hadoop cluster
picks them up and starts
sending tasks to them, right?
And while the job
is running, I want
to show you that we allow you
to see your standard Hadoop UI.
If you really, really,
really love your Hadoop UI,
and you know how to debug in
it, we allow you to do so.
You just need to set up the VPN.
It's pretty straightforward.
It's documented on a page.
And on this guy, we
can check the nodes.
And at this point,
it started with two,
but now we have way more
nodes, and they're all
processing our job.
OK, so with this, let's
switch back to the slides.
OK, so you've seen
me use a few ways
of accessing Rust APIs,
some from command line,
some from UI.
It's integrated with the
tools like Luigi and mrjobs.
So you can use those
tools, as well,
to run the jobs on a Dataproc.
There are three ways you
can actually run the jobs.
I did not demo the Hadoop one,
but essentially on that one
you would just
ssh on your master
and be able to run
like you usually do.
You've seen me a few
times, unsuccessfully,
resize the cluster, but
then I was successful.
But the challenge was the quota.
I selected the wrong zone.
But the point is it
was a click away.
And that's edit and change
the number of machines, right?
The thing I did not show you
all is that these clusters are
integrated with Stackdriver.
Stackdriver allows you to set
up the monitoring and logging.
So essentially all
the information
gathered about your cluster
will be preserved there,
and it can be turned into
really nice dashboards.
It can be set up such
that it causes alerts.
So if you have someone
monitoring your production,
they can actually be alerted
if things are not going
the way they're supposed to.
And you'll be able to
access your logs even
after you delete a cluster.
And to put it all
together, initially, we'll
probably just start with moving
the data away and putting it
in a cloud.
And then we'll
start experimenting
with workloads that are maybe
bursty or new applications we
want to run.
As we go along, we
may end up building
a hybrid infrastructure, where
you will host both your on-prem
and the GCP clusters.
And finally, you might end up
in a native cloud state, where
all your computations, all
your data lives in the cloud
and operates well with
all the other building
blocks that we have in Google.
To start, we have a
good documentation
on cloud.google.com/dataproc.
We also have many ways to get
help through our documentation,
through our release notes.
Stack overflow, we
scrub it all every day
and make sure we
answer the questions.
We have email lists that
you can send emails to--
Google Cloud Support.
And another one that is not
listed here is our partners.
So if this looks
like a daunting task,
you can partner with
many good companies
that are listed on our website
that can help you with this.
So with that, I'm happy
to take any questions.
[CLAPPING]
It seems like the
standard right here
is to ask questions
after the talk.
So thank you all for coming.
[MUSIC PLAYING]